um
hi everyone um and welcome to the
to the code breakfast um
i'm marcus and i'm a phd student
focusing on
on machine learning with time series and
one of the
core developers of sk time and i'm i'm
really happy
to to be here today and to work through
this tutorial
and with you um i'm joined by three
other
sk time contributors and that is um
franz kiri who's a part-time lecturer at
ucl
and a senior data scientist in industry
and that's patrick rockenshop
who's a phd student at ucl as well with
a focus on epidemiology
and ayushmann seth who's a computer
science
undergraduate student at ucl and they
will be in the chat
and happy to answer questions as we go
along
and help you out um wherever necessary
and we have 90 very exciting minutes
ahead of us i think
and um so the main goal is to introduce
you to machine learning with time series
and i think it would be nice if everyone
could um quickly write in the chat
high so that we kind of like get to know
each other a little bit
better before we before we start
okay nice okay so
this is a beginner-friendly tutorial and
we assume basic familiarity
with the pi data stack including panda
since i could learn
um but
not much more so no previous experience
of working with time series is
expected and it's also an interactive
tutorial and this is very important for
us
so we encourage you to ask questions
please use the chat
um please use the q a feature we
encourage you to run the notebooks
locally or on binder and so if you want
to launch them on binder
you can just go to the to the repo which
is up here
and then you can click the launch binder
button
and you will launch it in the cloud
otherwise you can clone the repository
up here and you can then download
the repository and launch the jupyter
number locally for more instruction i've
explained this here how to get started
but yes please um use the code to play
around with it
and we encourage you also to you to
raise an issue on github
if anything doesn't look right or or is
buggy
um so so just to emphasize this is a
this is a tutorial for you and we're
here to
kind of like guide you through it and to
help you
so the the main learning
objectives actually let me start the the
first notebook
um
yes so this is the the introduction
notebook
um
[Music]
the zero zero intro and
the main learning objectives are that
you learn about
the different machine learning problems
and learning tasks that you may come
across
when working with time series data
and especially how you can tell them
apart and you will also learn about
[Music]
different kind of specialized time
series algorithms
and different ways and to build
composite machine learning models to
solve these problems
um and the the goal of the tutorial is
not so much to
propose new algorithms or to kind of
like do
comparisons of algorithms to find out
which one is the best
but rather to highlight two things and
the first one is that
there are many problems in pitfalls when
you simply use um
kind of like psychic learn and to solve
time series problems
which is which is not designed um for
these types of learning tasks
and second that there are many
interesting and effective
other strategies of dealing with with
time series data
that go beyond what scikit learn and
most of the other kind like tabular
toolboxes can offer
and throughout the tutorial we will make
use of
sktime and sktime is a new python
toolbox
for machine learning with time series
and the idea of sk time is to extend
cycle learn
to the time series setting so we follow
psychic learns
logic and syntax wherever possible
so a lot of the code should look very
familiar to you
but we also develop and implement new
machine learning tools and techniques
especially for for time series
there are also an other a number of
other um
time series toolkits out there and here
i mention a few of them
and we have a more complete list of kind
of like related packages in
software in the python ecosystem
and when you follow this link in our
main repository
again feel free to chat to us or to
raise an issue if if anything is missing
and sk timer is a relatively young
toolbox
we started a bit over a year ago so some
features are still experimental
and will have to be consolidated in the
future so again please make us aware if
anything
and breaks or if you find any other
shortcomings or bugs
in terms of the structure um
we want to start by giving you an
overview of
the different time series data formats
that you may encounter in
real world problems and the different
learning tasks that you may need to
solve
when you have these data formats
um and then we look at two learning
problems in particular um forecasting
and time series classification and then
for each one
we will show you how you can solve these
tasks with them standard approach it
approaches um including psychic learn
algorithms but also more specialized
time series techniques
and algorithms which we provide in sk
time
and then we conclude by giving you an
outlook
of um how you can contribute to sk time
and where we kind of like csk time in
the future
um i think it also makes sense to have
um a 10 minute break in between so
perhaps after the first hour or so
that would be after the the forecasting
um session or notebook i think
okay so before we start um if you have
any questions now
please feel free to to ask them um
[Music]
and again please don't hesitate to put
them in the q a or chat
um it's it's i think it's the first time
for
for many of us to give an online
tutorial
so it's even more important to kind of
have like a um
to get some feedback and i i really
appreciate if you
um kind of like actively listen um by
giving me some reactions in the chat
um kind of like indicating whether you
can
whether you can follow me uh whether i
go too quickly or too slowly
um or whether anything is still unclear
and please also um please also
feel free to share related resources in
the chat
um and then all any any questions that
we that we cannot answer in the q
a on the chat now we will put on the
the discord and we we're happy to to
discuss it afterwards
okay so see there's one question in the
in the q a
um yeah so wait some of the questions i
will try to answer live and other
questions um
[Music]
um the the other contributors can just
answer quickly in the
in the chat um
so
[Music]
um is everyone ready to go with the
notebooks there's still an open question
on
yes okay so there are many questions now
in terms of
what's the kind of the difference of sk
time
and how it compares to existing
toolboxes um
in the throughout the tutorial we will
kind of like make references to
to other um to kind of like a paper that
we published on why we
created um sk time and i guess also
working through the tutorial will make
clear what the
what the purpose is of sk time and how
it compares to other toolboxes
in short um sktime is a unified toolbox
so many of the or all of the existing
toolboxes to our knowledge
um focus on a few particular learning
tasks like for example
profit focuses on forecasting um
and some of the other toolkits i
mentioned down here
and focus on time series classification
only or so on
and the idea with sk time is to create a
unified toolbox for time series
so that you can make use of kind of like
relations between the different learning
tasks
and use algorithms for one task and
to solve another task
okay um let's go to the
the first um proper notebook
and let's make a let's make it start
um so we'll start by doing some
conceptual groundwork
um and in this notebook we're trying to
give you
an overview of the landscape of machine
learning with time series
and i think this will really help us to
clarify some concepts
and to help us better understand what
machine learning with time series is
about
and in what respects it's different
from standard machine learning as
presented in scikit-learn
or in most textbooks and this will
hopefully also enable you
to go off on your own after the tutorial
and see where your own work is situated
and help you in your search for more
useful resources
and in particular you will learn about
different data formats that arise in a
temporal data context
and different learning tasks that may
arise
in in such a context and how to tell
them apart
and some of this may seem a bit obvious
to you but i think it's important to
clarify these concepts
um before we before we kind of like
start to
to do like write algorithms and try to
solve learning tasks
which out really without having
distinguished them clearly
um okay so time series comes in in many
shapes and forms
um and let's start with the kind of like
simplest case here
um so we only we only have a single
series
and to make this a bit more tractable we
will consider an example so let's
suppose
we are meant to analyze um data from a
chemical reactor um
and i guess the the the goal could be to
improve the outcome on or the product
of this kind of um chemical process um
or to like optimize um the control
system
in like a smart way and the chemical
process takes place in
in in this bioreactor we have
a little image here of the bioreactor
[Music]
and the bioreactor is essentially a
container
in which chemical processes are carried
out and it allows you to control the
process for example you can control the
inflow of oxygen or the
the speed of the aggregation system but
what we're mainly interested in is that
the bioreactor also allows you to
observe and measure
certain variables throughout the process
and yes in particular allows us to take
certain measurements repeatedly over
time
using some sensor in the reactor so this
gives us some time series data
and in the simplest case we observe a
single time series of measurements
and the time series that we observe
um consists of both the time points
at which we make measurements and and
the
the kind of values that we measured
and let's say that we measure the
pressure
inside of the reactor over time and
here i've prepared some data at the
bottom of the notebook you will find the
reference um to the dataset
and i've just written a little helper
function so in this first line
we just load the helper the the data
loading function
and then we can load the kind of the
prepared data
and we can plot the single series so
this is this is a single time series of
pressure
and now the the question is suppose that
we only have this time series
um what are some some real world
problems
that you may encounter and that you may
want to solve with machine learning
um so two of the
of the two uh most common ones are
time series annotation um and kind of
like special cases are
outlier or anomaly detection on
segmentation
and here you want to assign a label to
each
time point for example whether the
measurement
at a particular time point is an outlier
or not
or perhaps you want to find change
points in the process
um at which the kind of like the overall
dynamics of the
of the process fundamentally changed um
so in time series annotation may be
useful for um
if you want to develop like a live
warning system or as an analysis of
where potential falls occur during the
during the process that you observed
the other main learning task is
forecasting and here you want to make a
temple forward prediction
using um the available past data
and this may be useful to inform the
control system of potential future
changes to the process
so that you could have an early
detection
system that uses predicted data to make
um smart adjustments to the process
um okay so much for the kind like
simplest case
um how's everyone doing was that too
slow
too fast um are there any
any questions i see there's one in the
um one in the okay this is still an open
an old one
all right thanks all for all of the
feedback looks like
it's all going well
okay um
[Music]
so the next the next complication is
that you may observe
multiple series
and here it gets a bit more complicated
because this can happen in fundamentally
two
two different ways the first one is you
can have multivariate time series
where the time series are closely
related
or you can have panel data where you
observe independent instances
of the of the time series
and we start with multivariate data so
here we observe
two or more variables over time and for
example the pressure
and now also the temperature of the
process as well
and um just to kind of clarify some
terms here so variables
um represent different kinds of
measurement like for example temperature
or pressure
um and they we take them
within a single experimental unit in
this case the experimental unit is the
the the bioreactor run
so we observe a single bioreactor run
and we take different kinds of
measurements
um so it's important to note that we
still only observe a single bioreactor
run
and but now more than just one variable
and again we can ask the question
um that if we have this type of data
um what are some kind of like real world
problems
um that we may want to that we may have
to solve
and that we can actually answer with
this type of data
um so as before we have like variants of
the
of the annotation and the forecasting
tasks and but now we have access to
additional variables so we can make use
of them
and for example now we can use
not just the pressure but the pressure
and the temperature combined
to see if the the process at a
particular time point
um was was like an anomaly on outlier
or just a normal observation and
similarly with um forecasting
we could now use the additional variable
as an exogenous variable
and see if that can help us to
make better um predictions for the
for the future of the process or
and we could try to to forecast both
series
at the same time and so we forecast
multiple series at the same time and
this
is usually called vector forecasting
okay so the second way in which we could
observe
multiple series is panel data
or sometimes also called longitudinal
data
and this is where things change a bit
now
because here we observe multiple
independent instances
of the same kinds of measurements and
for example
readings from the same sensor from
different runs of the chemical process
or the the bioreactor
and i've plotted them here so each so
this is all
um different measurements of pressure
over time
and each color represents a different
run
and it's important to note that
this kind of like difference between
having multivariate data
where time series are related and
possibly the dependent on each other and
having panel data
where we can assume that the different
runs are statistically independent
and also note that panel data may be
multivariate um
so we can have um independent and
identically distributed instances
of multiple time series so we could have
observed pressure and temperature for
multiple runs
and in this case still the instances the
different bioreactor runs that we
observe
are independent but the
the time series and within each instance
may still depend on each other
also note that panel data may be mixed
so maybe we observe some time constant
variables
um for example maybe we observe some
fixed
settings of the bioreactor like the size
or some fixed and control variables
which cannot change over time
and again we can ask the question um if
we observe this type of data
what are some real world problems that
you may encounter
and that you may want to solve with
machine learning
and so we have
what we call supervised variants of the
annotation and the forecasting task
and this now basically works as follows
so
if you observe multiple runs um and you
have labels
for the time points for the different
series you can
try to learn the association between the
between the process and the label
for the from the training set from the
label data that you have
and then once you've learned this
association you can try to predict the
labels
of the new series that you get of a new
um bioreactor run which isn't labeled
yet
so that's kind of the supervised time
series annotation
variant um similarly for forecasting
um if you observe multiple bioreactor
brands you can
try to make use of um
[Music]
the consistent patterns across um
different bioreactor runs
um in order to predict the the
the future values of a of a single um
series and but also with panel data
we um can solve um
kind of like what we call series as
features learning tasks
um and these are direct extensions of
the learning tasks that we have in
scikit learn
so we have time series classification we
have time series regression
and time series clustering clustering
and what the goal is here is that we
observe a time series
and in classification we want to find
the relationship between
the series and an individual label so we
try to assign a label to an entire
series
and in classification this label is
discrete
and in the regression we have the target
variable um
which is continuous and then in
clustering
we're interested in finding um
clusters of time series based on the
similarity
between entire series
and i've hinted at this before um
we have to be aware of the kind of like
statistical
and dependency structure of time series
and i guess the first point is quite
obvious
but an intrinsic characteristic of time
series is that observations are
statistically dependent on adjacent or
past observations
so and this this already indicates that
they don't naturally fit into the
standard machine learning setting
as in cyclin where we assume to have
independent and identically distributed
instances
and yes i've explained this before as
well so in multivariate data
it is implausible to assume that the
different um
univariate time series like the
temperature and the pressure
that they are independent um
but when we have panel data it is
plausible to assume that the different
instances
um are independent while the well this
time series are still dependent on each
other
okay so and at this point um having kind
of like
um explained and outlined a little bit
the the
landscape of time series um you may
wonder
why why does it all matter why do i have
to care about this
and the main point here is that well
there are two main points so first of
all is that
in different learning tasks require
different types of algorithms
to solve them so for example if you want
to solve the time source classification
task you need an algorithm or you need a
time series classifier
if you want to solve a forecasting task
you need a forecaster
um now more importantly if you
misdiagnose the learning tasks
if you um think um that you have to
solve a different task then kind of the
actual real world problem um
requires um your algorithm
may still work when you when you build
it
in kind of like in your training
environment but it will no longer work
when you want to deploy it
because it it requires certain inputs
that are simply not there in the
in the deployment situation and
even if you misdiagnosed the task in
many cases you can still kind of get the
algorithm to work and you can still
obtain performance estimates
but um these estimates are not
are no longer reliable basically if you
do not take into account the
the dependent the statistical dependence
of the data
um so performance estimates tell us how
well our model will perform
once we deploy it and they basically
allow us to make informed
choices about which model to deploy but
our estimates are only reliable
if we properly take into account the
statistical dependence
of the data that we use to obtain these
um estimates
okay let me check if there are
[Music]
many questions in there no okay
so is is everyone still doing doing fine
before we move on
um i've seen this like an active chat
i really appreciate this thanks for all
of the the questions and comments
okay nice okay so let's
let's um move on so there are there are
a few more complications which we kind
of brushed over here now
um in many real world applications
we find um what we call time
heterogeneous data
so the instances or variables may not
share a common time index
and examples of this may be that you
have that the
that you have unequal length time series
data so maybe the
the number of time points that you
observe for the pressure variable are
not the same
as the the number of time points that
you observe for temperature
you may also observe them timestamp data
so
instead of observing um measurements at
a
like regular regularly spaced interval
you observe measurements at exact time
points
or for example maybe the different
sensors have different sampling
frequencies
um and so the the time indexes
do not um align so maybe the pressure
sensor
samples your the and the pressure from
the process at like a five second
frequency
and the temperature is um sampled at the
three second frequency
um and in general this kind of like
having these different data formats
raises the question
how to represent this kind of data and
for the purpose of
machine learning and
usually instances
what we describe here as instances so
they can like independent and bioreactor
runs
are represented in rows similarly we
have um
variables and or columns
um variables represented as columns
and then the time series setting
introduces a new dimension to it
kind of the temporal dimension the the
time points that we observed
um and it's not it's not immediately
clear how to like
best represent this um so there's
there's a like an ongoing
um debate about the which former to
choose
um so whether we want to choose the
white format where we
represent time points as columns but
that has certain drawbacks
or whether we want to choose the long
format um as in a relational
database or any other format and
similarly there seems to be no consensus
in the kind of like
python community about which data
container to use whether to use
numpy pandas or x-ray or even the custom
data container
and for more details on on this kind of
like issue of how to store and represent
and this kind of data you can look at
our wiki entry
and um and there's also a notebook which
we included which um patrick wrote
um on the data container development and
the
the kind of like thoughts and
considerations that we took into account
and um we're happy to answer more
questions if that's
of interest even either later or
in the discord afterwards
yes so regarding the the question in the
q a
um
[Music]
yes so if you yeah that's basically the
forecasting um
problem so if you observe um
[Music]
um for example the last year and you
want to
and let's say you have like monthly data
and then you want to predict um the next
month of the new year
and that will be a forecasting problem
we will explain the forecasting in more
detail in
in our next notebook where we focus like
exclusively on forecasting
okay so to to kind of like sum this up
um
we've discussed different times with
learning tasks in
briefly how to tell them apart and for
more details you can take a look at our
paper
and here we summarize the the different
learning tasks in
kind of slightly more mathematical terms
and you can read through them
um or go back to them if anything is
still unclear
or if you want to have like a slightly
more
like concrete and robust definition of
them
and now what's really interesting with
time series
is that there are so many kind of like
so many of these tasks that are
related and until now we focused on on
that these tasks are distinct but
there's this idea called reduction
which essentially says that an algorithm
for one task
in some cases can be adapted to help
solve another task
and a classical example of reduction in
supervised learning is
um one versus all classification
where you reduce um a k way
multi category classification so you
have k categories and you
you reduce it to k binary classification
tests
um in in the time series domain
um there's also very common example of
reduction
and that's when you try to solve a
forecasting task
with um kind of like regression
algorithms from psychic learn
and this is usually done as follows um
which we try to
to kind of like show in the in the
little diagram
and below here so you observe a time
series and you use a sliding window
to split this into um equal length
windows
and then you stack on top of these and
then you stack these windows on top of
each other
and that gives you your feature matrix
of lact
values and for each window you use the
the subsequent value um
as the kind of like target value that
you want to predict
and so this is kind of what we call the
like tabularization
of the time series and once you have
this like tabular matrix
you can um fit any cycle learn regressor
and then generate forecasts from it we
will just explain this again
in in the forecasting example more
detail here the main purpose is to show
that
there are many relationships between
time series learning tasks
and that's also one of the key reason
why it makes sense to have a unified
toolbox
so that you can fully exploit these
relationships
and here we kind of give you a quick
overview
of the different reduction relations
that
that we know of in the time series
domain
what i've just described and going from
classical forecasting
um to tabular regression in fact
involves the number of
intermediate steps and but you can also
of course kind of like directly reduce
forecasting to
tabular regression again if you want to
find out more
or look up the kind of like references
here in this little screenshot
um you can go to our paper
which we've also referenced down here
and
yes this is the the link to the data set
okay um so
this is kind of the the the conceptual
groundwork
um that i think we needed for
for the more practical work and
yes let me know if there are any
questions at this point before we move
on to the
to the more practical um
forecasting task
yes so the link to the the link to the
paper
um is right here is right under the
under the reduction diagram if you can
see it
um if not you will also find it on the
sk time repository
okay so um let's move on to the
can like first more practical notebook
um which is the notebook two on
forecasting
okay just to kind of like um recap
um in forecasting we're interested in
using pass data to make um tempo forward
predictions
and sk time provides um like algorithms
and tools for
for building composite machine learning
models to do that
um and in this notebook
um um we'll
um kind of like look at and both um
connect specific
or statistical models to make forecasts
but also
ways of building composite machine
learning models
including techniques like reduction to
progression
but also other techniques like
ensembling and pipelining
um and we'll kind of like work through
them
um step by step um and then
um you can again you can like play
around with the code and ask questions
and
um we can discuss them with more in more
detail
and okay so we just um
[Music]
load some preliminaries here
and then for this tutorial we use um
like a toy data set just to clarify kind
of the the concepts
um and this is an airline data set which
shows the number of
international airline passengers and
note that this is a monthly data
so the seasonal periodicity um is 12
and by the seasonal periodicity we kind
of mean the number of periods per year
at which we expect them to kind of like
see
um like a seasonal pattern and in this
in this plot you can see quite
clearly that there's a strong seasonal
pattern
now before we start building models to
make forecasts
um it is important to
specify what exactly we're trying to
predict
and this is something um which is done
very implicitly
in psychic learn and in succulent you
know we'll find
um you know we have to like explicitly
define the learning tasks that you're
trying to solve
instead this is like implicitly done by
your choice of estimators of whether you
choose a regressor or classifier
and also through the separation of the
of the x and the y the features and the
target
in the interface or or the signature of
the fit function
in forecasting you need an additional
piece of information
um namely the forecasting horizon
that is the the time points that you
want to predict
and here we define our learning task as
follows
so um we will try to predict the last
three years of data
using the previous ess training data so
each point in the series
represents months as i've said so we
should hold out the last and 36 points
as test data
and then we use a 36 step ahead
forecasting horizon to evaluate our
forecasting performance
and you can like quantify the accuracy
of our forecasts
we use smart p which is the symmetric
mean
absolute percentage error and to kind of
like interpret this
the lower smartphone means a higher
accuracy
now we can we can use this um the
temporal train test split function from
psychic learn air from sk
and define the test sites as 36
and then we can plot the data and we can
kind of like see
how we split the data into training in a
test set
let me load the data first
okay so we have 108 um
observations in the training set and 36
in the test set
okay as i've said we now need to define
the the forecasting horizon
and so the time points that we want to
predict
and here we define it as kind of the the
range from the first step ahead
and to the 36th step ahead
and we can simply define it as a numpy
array
um yes and we can then use this
forecasting horizon to
to make kind of the predictions for the
time points that we're interested in
of course you could also write it in a
different way so for example
if you were interested in predicting
only the the second and the fifth step
ahead
you could simply define the forecasting
horizon
as an array like this
um okay i think it it's usually a good
idea to
start with very like simple approaches
to solve your learning tasks
that usually helps to clarify a little
bit what we're trying to do
and um for forecasting two very simple
strategies
uh and first you always use the last
value that we observed
so that basically means if i want to
predict tomorrow um
i i just use the value of today
and the second strategy is if i want to
predict let's say tuesday i look at the
last tuesday so i use the last value of
the same season
now if i want to do the um predict the
last value observed to the first
strategy um i could write this in python
a single line
so we take the last value of the
training set here
and we just repeat it for the length of
the forecasting horizon and then i cast
it into panda series so that it has the
right index and that makes it easier
and to plot so we can just plot this and
the green line that you see here
this is basically the the prediction of
the last value
[Music]
okay we can also do this in sk time
and similar to sk time we have um a
similar to cycle learn i mean we have um
a naive forecaster or like a dummy
forecaster
so we can easily specify it and and this
syntax should be very similar to
should be very familiar to to anyone who
knows cycle learn
so we first build or specify the model
and we can
choose the hyper parameters here
and we then once we have specified the
model we can fit it and here we use the
single
training series and then once we have
the fitted model
we now pass the forecasting horizon to
predict
to generate these predictions and then
again we can plot the data and obviously
it looks the same
and we can also compute the the
smartphones
um now if we choose a different strategy
so to solve kind of the
the the to use the other strategy the
simple strategy we can
change the strategy hyperparameter and
put in season or last
and at the same time provide the
seasonal periodicity of the data
which is 12 in this case and then you
can see that
this basically repeats the last season
that we've observed
into the future and this already
captures the kind like seasonal pattern
a lot better
so there's one question in the okay i
think it has been answered already
um okay so this this should um kind of
clarify and what we're trying to do
and now obviously we're we're interested
in not just building naive forecasters
but kind of like more sophisticated
models
which hopefully capture like um
underlying trends and
patterns of the data in a better way
and now of course the question is uh can
i not just use psychic learn
and the answer is yes in principle
but there may be many pitfalls and that
you should be aware of
and that you should try to avoid so the
first one
which is also maybe the most obvious one
is
if you just use um the trained test
split function from psychic learn
and you split your data you basically
get something like this
so train test split in scikit-learn
is built for the setting where we have
independent
instances so it makes sense to shuffle
them and to randomly split them into
training in a test set
now in time series data you have a
different statistical dependency
structure
so you cannot just randomly shuffle the
data because
observations depend on past observations
and if we would use this kind of like
randomly split data
we would run into a problem which is
called
leakage so here the data that you're
using to train a machine learning
algorithm
happens to have the information that
you're trying to predict
so basically if we use this data to
predict the last
um 36 um steps then
as you can see there's already a lot of
training data there that the algorithm
sold
in training so it makes it quite easy to
predict this um
time period and but of course you could
um use train
test split from psychic learn and set
shuffle equal to false
and this is essentially what we do in in
the temporal trend test
in sk time and when you do this it works
it splits the
it kind of like properly splits the time
series and makes sure that you
properly evaluate the performance of
your algorithm
um okay so the the second pitfall is
that um it's not
it's not immediately clear how to use
scikit-learn
since we only have a single series and
this brings us back to the kind of like
idea of reduction so what we're
essentially trying to do when we use
cycle learn is to
reduce the forecasting tasks that we're
meant to solve to a regression task so
that we can apply circuit learn
regressor
and um we can do this as follows so
again we we first need to transform the
data into the
required tabular format so that we can
put it into the circuit land regressor
and as i've said before we do this by
using like a sliding window
we cut the series into windows stack
them on top of each other
and then always use the subsequent value
as the
the target variable that we're trying to
predict
and we could write some code for this um
so
for example in the m4 competition which
is a famous um kind of like
forecasting competition um
we they have written some code and i use
like a slightly modified version here
and this function basically does this um
kind of like transformation of the data
for us
so we it takes in a single series um
it also needs the number of the kind of
like
when the window length which is um the
in num
and it needs the the forecasting horizon
or the length of the forecasting horizon
and here the number of um out of sample
points that we want to predict
um okay if we
if we run this function now what i do
first to kind of like
um illustrate a little bit how it how it
works
and i put in not the the time series
values but i put in the
the time index basically of our time
series
i set the window length to 10 and i give
the length of the forecasting horizon
now if we run this i need to define
the the forecasting will rise and here
we go
now if we run this um
we can look at the kind of like feature
matrix that we get in terms of the time
index
and this looks as follows so the first
window is from the first observation
to the ninth so it's got length 10
second one is from 1 to
10 and so on so we kind of use we we can
see this like sliding window
and then corresponding to these windows
we have the target um
variable which for the first window
consists of the next value
for the second window it's the
subsequent value and so on
now this is when we use the the time
index
now we actually supply the the time the
actual values that we observed
um and then do the
the data transformation again um
we can kind of see the shapes of the
arrays
and so we have our feature matrix of
lack var
of lag values has um 98 rows
and as expected kind of like a window
length of 10
so we look at the 10 lakh values
and then we have the training target
variable of the same
length okay and once we have this kind
of like format this is what this is what
circuit learn needs
so we can just use any regressor from
psychic learn
in this case i chose the brandon forest
and then we can just put it in and fit
the model
now this all seems to work quite nicely
but we believe that there are like a few
problems with this
and first of all um
this requires a lot of handwritten code
which is often error prone and it's also
not modular
or and not tunable so by modular i mean
it's very hard to change certain
components of this kinelic process
by tunable i mean that
this this process this type of reduction
involves a number of
of implicit hyper parameters which we
may want to optimize
so one of them is for example the window
length so the performance of
the algorithm of the random forest and
of this entire reduction approach
is likely to depend on the window length
that we choose
so we may want to optimize the value
that we have
by using like a temporal
cross-validation scheme
another hyper parameter is the strategy
that we use to generate forecasts
now we have the fitted model but we
haven't actually generated
any forecasts um so far
and how to do that is another kind of
like modeling choice
um that we have to make as a as a
like a practitioner or scientist and
we want to in some cases we may want to
optimize this and
using this kind of like handwritten
approach and all of this is like very
difficult to implement
now before i show you how we can do this
in sk time in a much better way
i want to kind of like show you how you
can generate forecasts
once you have this fitted model
so um if we print the shapes of the
test set and how the feature
matrix of the test set and the target
variable tested
and we can see that we have um 36
windows
and each one is 10 long so that seems to
be in the right format
and we have um kind of the target
variable
is is the same this is going to be kind
of like our test set so this is what we
compare our predictions against
and now what we can do is we can simply
put this
in the um in the fitted model
and compute the loss
okay and now the question is what's the
problem here
so this seems to be kind of the the most
natural way of generating predictions
um but given the learning tasks that we
defined it's actually
wrong and i think it's important to
understand what's going on here
so when we put in these 36 windows
we use the actual test data
rather than using um kind of like
predicted value or something like this
so in other words instead of making
multi-step ahead forecast so instead of
predicting
instead of having a fixed cutoff point
and predicting
36 steps ahead what we actually do here
is we make
36 single step
predictions so we always move the cut
off
[Music]
but that's a solution to different
learning tasks
and as you can see we can still compute
the loss
and but this loss will be will be
much more optimistic than than the
actual
loss um if we tried if we predicted 36
steps ahead
because predicting only a single step
ahead having almost
always the the most recent data
available
um is likely to be simpler than than
predicting um 36 steps ahead
so that's i think that's an important
pitfall to kind of like be aware of
and now to fix this problem um
we could write some code to do this
recursively um
as in the m4 competition
[Music]
so what we do here is we define kind of
like an empty list
for the final predictions and then we
get the last window
of the available data that we have so
in this case it's the the training set
and we use only the last window
and then we reshape it to make it into a
2d array so that we can use it in second
learn
and then we use only the last window
that we have
and we generate a prediction and then we
kind of like do this recursively so
we iterate over the forecasting horizon
and for each step of the forecasting
horizon
we first kind of like append or store
our prediction and then we update the
window
and we update the window by using the
last predicted value that we have
so we use the the previously predicted
value
to to update the the new window and then
once we've updated the window we can
make a new prediction
of the next step ahead and we do this
recursively until we've
predicted all of the steps ahead um
and then um we can again compute the
loss
and as you can see so this loss um a
smaller loss means a better accuracy
and you can see that if we do it this
way the loss is actually
um higher so with this one with this
approach we would have um overestimated
the performance
of the of the algorithm
okay is this clear so far are there any
any questions how's everyone doing
okay nice um
[Music]
so with sk time um we kind of like
try to make this much more convenient
for users
we encapsulate this reduction step into
a meta algorithm
to make it modular and compatible with
cycle learn but also tunable
and adaptive in the sense that it adapts
the cycle scikit-learn estimate
interface to that of a forecaster
and that makes sure that we can tune it
and properly evaluate our model and
basically that we
avoid the the pitfalls described above
um and this is this is kind of what we
try to represent in this diagram
so we can like wrap the outer robot here
is the the reduction meta estimator
and it wraps the the smaller robot
inside the psychedelic regressor
okay again we can load the airline data
and we can do the tempo train test split
and then we can import from scikit-learn
this reduced regression forecaster which
is essentially an auto-regressive um
um regressor so to say so it uses the
lag values as described above
and then we can again use any psychic
learn regressor in this case we now pick
a
k nearest neighbors regressor
we specify the regressor and then we
pass the regressor to the regressed
regression forecaster
and with certain hyper parameters so
here we use the window length of 12
which is the kind of like seasonal
periodicity and we use a recursive
strategy to
make predictions and then this forecast
has the same interface as all of the
other forecasters
we can fit with the training series and
predict with the forecasting horizon
and then generate the predictions
and yeah so this is what i've described
before
this is kind of like how internally we
we split the window
i don't think i have to go over this
again
um so this is kind of the the idea if we
want to reduce the learning task to
a tabular learning task um
[Music]
sk time has also other statistical
forecasters
um and like exponential smoothing
or auto reamer which we interface from a
nice package called pmd arima
which is linked here in the text and
in the interest of time i won't go i
won't go through this
in detail i just skip over to the kind
of like more interesting part that sk
time has to offer
and this is kind of the the composite
model building functionality
um so and one aspect of it
is um ensembling and like sk
likes i could learn and we have a an
ensemble forecaster
and where we can combine multiple
individual forecasters
and then average the the predictions
and we're currently in the process of
developing more kind like sophisticated
ensembling strategies
um to to combine the forecasts of
individual forecasters
and this syntax again should be fairly
familiar to anyone who knows circuit
learn
and um just to kind of like reiterate
the ensemble forecaster
and wraps individual forecasters but at
the same time
it's a forecaster itself so it has the
same
fit and predict interface as all of the
other forecasters
now that's ensembling and you can also
do tuning
um in a forecasting setting um which is
something
that sk time provides so we have the
forecasting grid search cv
and we have different um temporal cross
validators
here we use a sliding window splitter um
and again we can we define an initial
window
that we use for training the algorithm
and then
we define we slide over the test set in
order to
to evaluate it for tuning and then once
we have found a good algorithm
through this grid search cv um we again
evaluate it on the
on the test set so in this case what we
try to tune
is the reduced progression forecaster so
this kind of like meta estimator and
specifically we try to find the best
window length
here i only look at um kind of like five
possible values whether 5
10 or 15 is the best choice of course
you could have a
bigger grid of um of values to search
over
and then once we run this um we will
find that the best parameter is 15
and the kind of like the grid search tv
will be the
and we can then kind of use this with
the best value to predict to make
predictions as i could learn
[Music]
um now another very interesting approach
is is residual boosting or de-trending
and in sk time we we do this um in a
modular way
so here the idea is that you want to
de-trend the time series
and as we can see here so this the blue
line is kind of the original
training set and there's a clear kind of
like linear
trend in the data and
um what we can try to do is fit this
linear trend
and then subtract the trend from the
data so that we only get
the residuals and this is what we do
here so we define
a polynomial trend forecaster of degree
one so this is just like a linear trend
um forecaster and we have this um
the trender um which is a transformer
a time series transformer which
internally fits the forecaster which we
passed to it
and then um returns the residuals of the
time
series um
and this is basically what's happening
here so
the yt um is what we plot here and this
is kind of the
the residuals which we show here
now this is um kind of like interesting
to pre-process the time series
but you can of course also use this as
kind of like a boosting
um strategy for forecasting
so you could fit um any type of
forecaster here
um and and use the forecaster to
the trend the series so now we use like
a just a linear trend forecaster
but of course you could also use
something much more complicated
like in a rima model or so to de-trend
the
series with the rima model and then
on top of the residuals from the rima
model so everything that the arima model
didn't capture
you can try to fit the more complicated
machine learning algorithm and this is
kind of the idea
of the detrender and we show here how
you can like
combine it in a pipeline um
so we we have a transform target
forecaster
which makes sure that you do target
transformations in the correct way in sk
time so in here the idea is that um
you first want to do some
transformations of the data
for example you want to take out the
kind of like seasonal pattern of the
data
and we use the kind of like standard
seasonal decomposition technique here
and then once you've de-seasonalized it
you want to get the
kind of like a linear trend out of the
data which is what we do next
and then once you have the de-trended
series
you want to fit um the more complicated
model
and in this case we use the k-nearest
neighbors again
and through this kind of like reduction
approach and we can all put this into a
single pipeline
and again then we have the just the same
interface so we can fit and predict
um and as you can see this strategy
already works fairly well
but again this is this is not about um
showing which algorithms are best
um but motor can like show you different
different concepts
of how to solve a forecasting problem if
you're interested in kind of like
algorithmic comparisons
um we've um used these different
techniques and evaluated them on the m4
study
and you can find the link to the paper
at the bottom
um and of course you can also look at
the m4 casting
um competition itself um
okay there's a question prediction
window still
so the the prediction window is still um
kind of like
what we're trying to do is still kind of
like encode it in the forecasting
horizon
so the forecasting horizon here is
still 36 so we still try to predict from
the first step to the
um to the 36th step ahead
um the window length 15 is what's kind
of the look back
how many points in the past um
are we trying to to use in order to make
this prediction
in this kind of like um reduction
approach
um okay there are also other ways
um of kind of like this changes the
learning task basically now the
um if you want to make like more dynamic
predictions uh this is kind of like an
online learning setting
um where you um
want to update your prediction as soon
as you get new data
so um and we have a specific um function
for this kind of the update predict
function
where you can evaluate your model um for
different learning tasks
um like this one um so the dynamic
forecast
um just as the kind of like prediction
intervals which we show here
a still work in progress in sk time
and um not kind of like comprehensively
implemented for all forecasters
um and but yes
if you're interested um please get in
touch
um we're kinda like happy to push this
further and this is client
part and this is this is also on top of
the kind of like
development roadmap
um okay so in summary um
we've seen how to make forecasts and
we've seen like different forecasting
strategies
um ensembling and detrending and
pipelining as kind of like novel
techniques
that go beyond scikit-learn
and which we provide an sk time in which
seem to work
relatively well in practice
um i've added some links for more
resources here
and this is the paper that which i
mentioned
where we try out these different
approaches this is a very good
introductory textbooks on forecasting
and then more generally take a look at
the m4 competition
and they're currently running next
iteration of that competition the m5
competition
um okay so i think it makes sense to
have a quick break
um before we go into the classification
um
notebook and we're already running a bit
behind i think so maybe only
a few minutes i need to get some water
just a quick comfort break
and then i think we we can meet back at
um 9 15 and 3 minutes before we
and then go into the classification
notebook
i hope that's okay for everyone let me
let me know in the chat how everyone is
doing
or if you have any more specific
questions
okay i'll be i'll be back in in a minute
yeah so there's one question in the q a
um that's that's correct
um all of the steps in the pipeline must
have an inverse transformation
you first transform the data
you then fit the forecaster um
and generate forecasts and then you need
to inverse
the the forecasted values to kind of
like bring them back to the original
scale
i hope that that answers the question
[Music]
so how's everyone else doing
can everyone still follow
any any more so someone raised a hand
i've seen this before um
please um instead of raising your hand
please um put it into the chat or
or raise the question in the q a
okay there's still the um there's still
the question for
how it compared to fb profit
and i've mentioned this before um the
main difference is that
sk time is a unified toolbox so profit
only user
can only be used to solve forecasting
problems
um sk time as we will see in the next
notebook can also be used to solve other
um time series related learning problems
and yeah i hope this this answers the
question
and i also see that there are many kind
of like practical
um questions in about like in which
situations would in a riemann what would
be better
than a machine learning model and these
are kind of like very hard to
to answer in general i recommend the
textbook
which i've linked at the bottom and also
to kind of look at the different
benchmarking studies
okay maybe one short point about
facebook profit
to my to my knowledge it just implements
a very specific forecasting method
so it would be it would compare to a
framework toolbox to sk time like the
random forest brymen's random forest
compares to sqlearn
yeah i think that's right
it's it's a fairly flexible model though
that they have
um and well it's always a random for it
yeah yeah
okay um if there are no more urgent
questions at this point
um let's move on to the next notebook
and which is um time to use
classification
so this is a is kind of now in the panel
data setting
and i've tried to kind of like show
what's going on in this diagram here
um where we have um
training series which are labeled and we
have multiple instances of those
of those and then the goal is to to we
get a new
series and we want to label the new
series so we basically want to learn the
association between the series
and the labels
um so we import a number of functions
from sklearn and
sk time and then the specific data
that we look at in this um notebook
is known as the arrowhead problem
so we're basically trying to classify
the type of
arrowhead based on the outline
and this kind of like shows that um
timespeed classification
um can be used to solve a wide variety
of problems
so in basically how how you can go from
shapes to time series
is explained here so let's look at so
here they try to
can like um transform the and the shape
of a skull
into time series and if we look at kind
of like here panel c
um if we start at the mouth this gives
us our first time point so we
the the height here is the distance from
the center point
to the outline point and then we move
around it
um in like a clockwise fashion and we
always record the distance from the
center point to the up and to the
outline and then we kind of get this um
we transform the the outline of the
shape into the time series
and then we can try to see if the
different outlines
if they help us to predict the the type
of skull or in this case the type of
arrowhead
um and so in sk time we can have this
data set already so we can easily load
it
and we have in our training set we have
158
instances and they're all univariate so
for all of them we have a single time
series
now this is where it gets um maybe for
some of you
somewhat unintuitive and if we look at
the data
and this is basically what this like
panel data frame looks like
so each cell has an entire time series
in it
so if i take my x train
and i look into my first cell and it has
an entire time series in it
and the first number here is the index
the time index
and then we record the measurement value
so
for the zeroth index we observe this
value for the first time index we
observe this value and so on
so we um represent
entire time series as kind of like
columns
rather than just having um primitive
values like
floats integers or strings
as in kind of like the usual way of how
you would use pandas or
or numpy
and again if you want to find out more
why we make this choice
take a look at the wiki entry here
where we discuss this in more detail
if we look at the the our kind of like
target variable
we see that we have three classes
they're not perfectly equally balanced
um and we can plot them kind of like
here i just plot like the first instance
of each label
to kind of see what the the out the the
time series looks like of the different
arrowheads
and again we can ask the question um why
not just use some
so i could learn and again the answer is
that yes you can use scikit-learn
but um again you should be aware of them
certain kind of like implicit modeling
choices that you make when you use
scikit-learn to solve these issues
and there are basically two ways of how
you could do this
so the first way is um you treat each
time point
as a separate feature um
so we can this is again what we call
tabularize here
so you can um go from from this format
up here
where you have time series columns and
to this format here
where each time point now represents a
column
and this is a kind of like a standard 2d
matrix
um so you can use this and to fit your
cyclone regressor
now the the underlying modeling
assumption here is that
the the orderedness and time
of these observations doesn't play a
role
um so a tabular regression algorithm
cannot make use of the fact that the
columns are ordered
if you would reshuffle the the columns
um
you would still get the the same kind of
like
result the same fitted model and the
same predictions
um but we can use this um tabularized
training data
to for example fit like uh just to get
like a baseline for comparison
we can fit the dummy classifier or we
could fit a random forest classifier um
sk time provides also like a transformer
for this operation
so you can make a pipeline where you
first tabularize the data and then you
fit the random forest classifier
and you can run this as like a
encapsulated um meta estimator
so this is what i've explained in terms
of the the implicit modeling choice here
um and sometimes this works well and in
some cases it may be suitable
but sometimes it doesn't work well so
here the the kind of like what we want
to
to kind of like show is that um
that there is an implicit modeling
choice and that you should be aware of
this and that there may be other
strategies which are
um more suited to the program that
you're trying to solve
um the other the other way so if we back
in this case
um where we have and features
the other way to go to the tabular
setting is to use feature extraction
so we could from each series that we
have we could extract certain features
and then this would also bring us back
to the tabular setting of psychic learn
and there's a a nice toolbox for this
called tears fresh
and it does like automatic feature
extraction for you
so here we kind of like show what this
looks like
we use our kind of like um panel data
um data frame and we extract features
from it
and then we can see that for we have
like different variables so here for
example we
extracted the length here we extracted
the maximum value here we extracted the
mean the median
and so on and you can extract them a
number of
features this is kind of the the minimal
number of features you can also
use different settings to get many more
features
and then once we have this um data frame
again you can um
you can fit a random forest classifier
so
in sk time you can formulate this as a
pipeline
um with the feature extractor first and
then the random forest
[Music]
okay i want to um show you one of the
other kind of like more specialized time
series classification algorithms which
we provide in sk time
which um um shows like a number of
interesting um
kind of things that you can do with time
series and this is called time series
forest and it's a
modification of the random forest
algorithm
so the steps are you first so for each
instance
you take the series and you split it
into multiple random intervals
then the second step is for each
interval you extract them a number of
features
and they can like original
implementation you extract the mean
the standard deviation and the slope
and then you basically if you extracted
10 random
intervals and you extract three features
from each of them
you end up with um 30 features for each
instance
and then based on that matrix you train
a decision tree
and then you ensemble um steps one two
three
so you ensemble this entire pipeline
including the data transformations and
the final decision tree
so in sk time we could write this as um
as this you can like somewhat shorter
form
and but this one here um explains it
better i think
so this these are the steps of the
pipeline
and then the first step you choose a
number of intervals so here we use the
square root of the length of the time
series
and then for each interval we we
transform
we extract the mean the standard
deviation and the time series slope
and then based on these features we fit
a um decision tree classifier from
circuit learn
and this gives us an individual um kind
of time series tree
and we can use that as well but we can
also ensemble this
so we fit multiple of these multiple
trees
and then average their predictions and
this is what we do in the timeless
forest
classifier
and another cool feature of this is that
we can still get um
feature importances from this algorithm
and since we're working in the time
series domain
um we can get um
kind of the feature importance graph so
we can understand the feature
importances
over time and this basically works by
aggregating
the importance of each feature from each
interval
and then kind of like normalizing it by
the number of intervals and estimators
and this may help us to like to better
understand um
which parts of the time series and which
which features of the time series
are important to to discriminate between
the two classes
or the three classes in this case
another variant of this is called random
interval spectral ensemble
in the economic time series
classification literature
and it works in the same way but here we
now extract them
different features so we extract the
the autocorrelation um here the
autocorrelation coefficients we also
extract the
autoregressive coefficients
and the the coefficients of the power
spectrum
um but apart from that the the pipeline
is the same
and then we can ensemble it again using
this time series forest classifier
where we now pass the the rice the
random interval spectral ensemble tree
into um
[Music]
okay another interesting approach to
time series is
[Music]
is k-nearest neighbors and in
psychic learn what you do when you do
k-nearest neighbors classification
is you look at the distance between
individual data points
and you use something like the euclidean
distance and you always do like a
pairwise comparison
um when you want to compare entire time
series of course you could take the
euclidean distance between each time
point and then average this
but this usually doesn't work
particularly well
and the reason is that time series may
be slightly shifted
as you can see this image that the
bottom line is one time series
and the top line is one time series and
they're just slightly shifted
and the euclidean distance wouldn't be
um
very small for these time series but
when you allow
the kind of like matching between time
points when you give some kind of like
slack to it and you allow this to be a
bit more flexible so that you can find
the nearest closest point
when you compute the distance um you can
you can kind of like define a similarity
measure
which is much more suited to comparing
time series
and this similarity measure is called um
is usually called dynamic time warping
or this idea of um
warping the series so that they align
and better with each other and i've
linked the wikipedia entry which is
i think fairly well written so you can
read more details on there
and we have this implemented in sk time
so here we load a different data set um
which is a basic motions data set so
we record the um the
activities of students wearing like a
smart watch
and they do different activities um they
play batman then they run they stand and
they walk
and the idea is can we use this kind
like profile
of movement to predict the class um
and if you look at the kind of like if
we plot all of the instances for
for badminton um they look very messy
and they don't look as if they follow
the same kind of like pattern
and the same for running so if we
if we would just use the euclidean
distance it wouldn't work very well
but then if we allow them to to be
aligned
and through dynamic time warping it
works much better
and and we can show this here so this is
the standard cycle lone classifier with
the euclidean distance
and this is from sk time the k nearest
neighbor's time series classifier using
the
dynamic time warping
um this is um
kind of like you could find out other
classifiers that we have and extra
resources here
now it's 9 30 and this is kind of the
end of the talk before we finish
i want to quickly outline how you can
get involved and how you can get started
so this is in the how to contribute a
notebook
so you can check out um the good first
issues that we have
um please feel free to hang out in the
um
discord after the after the talk and get
in touch
feel free to raise an issue or to chat
to us um
[Music]
and it's all contributions are welcome
so not just code
um so we have a lot of people who like
write them tutorials or
if you help us out by by designing
the toolbox and the interfaces and
yes so sk time is really a community
driven
project and where we would be very
grateful if you would get involved and
give us some feedback
all right thank you very much
thank you that was uh that was a really
nice talk
thanks good job i think you you managed
to
to work it out well even though virtual
yep
yeah nice so uh yeah normally this is
the moment you you ask for like an
applause but that doesn't really work
as well nowadays um but yeah thanks i
just been checking the discord in the
chat here and people seem to have really
enjoyed it
okay nice um yeah for follow-up indeed
what you said
the discord is available we're also
hosting sprint on saturday so actually
if you
if you got inspired by sk time and want
to contribute
maybe saturday is also a good time to to
meet some like-minded people there and
try to contribute a bit there's also an
interesting talk at um
lunch today by adrian um
[Music]
yes yes yeah it's just about to say that
the schedule for today is
still very very interesting we have a
sprint preparation
session on writing unit tests where
giovanni lonzani will
actually show a unit test that he
written for pandas in preparing this
the sprint prep session after that we'll
interview
adrian so adrian is a core developer for
psychic learn he's been involved with
another project called fair learn as of
recently
and we just want to pick his brain a bit
on sort of the things that he
is seeing there and tonight we have
three more uh
three more talks um on feature stores
on um how it is to contribute to open
source
and uh some lessons learned from
managing an open data platform and using
data for
specific good so hope to see you all
then and i hope to see you in discord
for now thanks